I never let anybody else control my
destiny my mom's taught me to make
things happen on my own not to depend on
anybody and if I have an opinion to
speak on it you want to win it all you
want to go to the Final Four how do you
want to go to the Final Four but your
schedule don't look like the Final Four
what are you tweeting about when you
wrote that's why I'm willing to kill
every single man in my path to get that
belt in tournament is to secure the
future
what's that belief nation it's happened
my one word is believe and I believe in
you I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out into the world now I started the one
rule series because I do a lot of tough
tens and there's some rules that come up
over and over and over again and so once
a week we look at what are some of the
common rules that continue to come up
and smoosh those together into one video
for you so today we're gonna learn how
you can make it happen
enjoy
[Music]
was there some pivotal moment for you in
your life where you just really got it
and and something happened a fire
ignited inside you that made it so that
you had all the moving parts to make
this amazing career unfold I think the
death of my mother probably got me
really focused and I understood that
there wasn't gonna be anyone there to
take care of me had to take care of
myself and just out of respect for her
life and all the things she did to make
me a better person I had to apply all
those things so you know at like 17 my
mother died when I was 16 or 17 you know
I was running the streets so heavy and
it was getting so critical then I put
myself in boarding school you know I
figured out how to get a scholarship and
because of the ability that my mother
gave me to articulate what's on my mind
to read to write you know cannot be
afraid and also I was you know boxing so
I got went to the boys club and they
were given our scholarship for you know
he took a test I passed the test and you
know I made it and I was just always
able to put myself in a better place I
never let anybody else control my
destiny my mom's taught me to make
things happen on my own not to depend on
anybody and if I have an opinion to
speak on it now a lot of young people
are the black mamba the black mamba let
me tell you something when you talk
about the black mamba you talk about
practice it's a must have I watch this
dude lose a game a game I don't even
know if it was the playoffs I think it
was like a regular game against the
Miami Heat
in Miami South Beach Florida I don't
know if you ever been there before but
it's you want to go it's a bit a nice
place to just hang out especially if
you're on the road playing ball it's a
nice place after the game to go get
dinner sit on the beach it's the night
and I'm sure of you in ba they've
probably got a VIP section for them on
the beach
and unfortunately Lakers lost to the
Miami Heat because Black Mamba missed
the wide-open shot in the corner set
shot in mystery what he did for the next
3-4 hours why everybody was getting
dressed and going on the beach he sat
there for hours shooting the exact same
shot over and over and over and over
like here number one championship I'd
like now hold up where everybody else at
home the Lakers they need to be out
there as a squad like up but but the
Black Mamba is out there doing this
thing like I'm not on them I messed up I
gotta practice and this is not a coach
practice this is not an organism or the
organization in call this one this was
just flat-out the Black Mamba was saying
this is a must-have and where most of
you go wrong
you're not even 4.0 and you not studying
like you're not even a 4.0 student like
you got a two point A to five a three
something and you still not really study
it like that because for you is my eyes
not a must-have it blows my mind I
worked with professional athletes I work
with d1 athletes all over the world and
when I look at Twitter and Instagram it
blows my mind how dudes on Instagram I'm
like run you have not won a championship
like that's what you come here for to
win a championship and so if you don't
win the championship I don't even know
why his people broke I don't even know
how you have enough time to do a
30-second video you rode how did you
have time to do a video how to grab time
like to do a dance routine when you
should be practicing you should be
lifting weights you should be looking at
film you said not me that you want to
win the tourney that you want to win it
all you want to go to the Final Four how
do you want to go to the Final Four but
your schedule don't look like the Final
Four
what are you tweeting about when you
wrote hey I was broke do you understand
I was broke
when I was 25 dead broke I'm not talking
about financially broke let me tell you
something no I didn't have any money in
my pocket I didn't have any credit cards
nobody would give me credit okay didn't
have a driver's license okay
1970 Ford Maverick had a 1970 Ford
Maverick no air no heat no door handles
the freakin floor was rusted ok I lived
in a 275 square foot apartment maybe 300
square feet if he counted a little step
out in the front of the front door pay
two seventy five a month and I was late
almost every month so don't tell me
about you money problems man okay don't
tell me about where you were born
don't tell me about your bad brakes
don't tell me about what your daddy did
or your uncle felt you up or something
to some kind of weird thing to you know
I'll ruin your head or your sister
abused you or whatever okay look we all
got problems
you got to fix your problems now you got
to get your money right so 25 years old
I'm like I'm getting my money right I'm
done no more excuses no more crybaby no
more blame I'm getting my freaking money
right what you're working in the
plumbing business I was working in the
plumbing business at the time he ever
and I'm telling it was it would have
been around that time that John and
lastly I had left the flooring business
I left the flooring business how bad was
a diploma yeah horrendous
were you actually in the trenches I mean
it was an industrial so I'll be like
building this if you like diploma that
would be needed in a place like this six
o'clock in the morning and the morning I
used to have to walk for about an hour
to get that up to get there on motorway
and then I stand on the edge of the
motorway and wait for a bloke to drive
boy so give me a lift and then the
motorway was like getting renovation
that time so take me two hour or two
hours to get to the place was out in the
country gonna be there for ten hours
walking and I was a first year so as the
worst of the war sermons on the
beginning then two hours to get back in
the traffic again was just a horrible
horrible time and I was like you know
what I don't want to deal with this and
then I just left and then I just stopped
on didn't get
Beth and me died with him in to try and
Bank me out of bed and we have fights
and leisure for a good world I never
spoke I didn't really speak to me Danny
you just kind of stayed away from each
other anytime I only time I come across
me that I just I come we did speak was
foot was to fight he lived in his house
yeah little need anything anything you
didn't talk to him isn't that it cut
awkward like it wasn't you know you have
a just a deep relationship but since
this since this is happy right since the
dream has happened since the vision that
I had has come true and like he went
through he went through tough times over
because he got testicular cancer so he
got sick and all over and there in my
head us thinking maybe maybe I don't
that because he's worried about me
that's not what I'm gonna do when all
these fights that were having all the
time but I'm talking full-on fights come
in and points it but no not here we go
now you're punching back but yeah we
were going out of here wow what did your
mom say about that it was so protective
of you yeah I mean well I don't know it
was just she just stayed out in a book
and but seems to get to that point
toward he was that because I was doing I
was doing absolutely nothing in the
trouble yeah basically felt like I was
down for God I was a waster you know I
was a waster got that call that a lot
and I remember but now like and then and
then when I when I start getting that
focus and realize enough I'm gonna I'm
gonna make this happen
and then never has happened I'm I'm I'm
making it happen
I have a great relationship with that
like we talk all the time and I even see
energy and I see energy and you might
like it's the present times for a lot of
people around there's a lot of bad stuff
going on and in the country a lot of
people are struggling everybody's
struggling but now since since them
seeing me chase this dream it's given
them an energy and I see a new lease of
life in them and that alone spores me on
even more so it's all just a perfect
storm that's happening for me and that
is why I have this tunnel vision and
that's why I'm willing to kill every
single man in my path to get that belt
in Memphis to secure the future from my
family's future I mean that's that's
what I'm dealing for it's hard to say
but when I was a kid I used to I always
like when I was a kid he's always
visualized Stadium something and like
even when I was playing football I'd
kick the ball against the wall and I
pretended I scored a goal and I'd run
off and I'd be raising my hand and
visualizing a arena full of fans and
that was something I don't as a kid I'm
out on my own I like just running around
kicking the ball so I always had these
visions of something but I just didn't
know what it was and then I suppose when
I came to this of these events I know it
started training me and then came to an
event I was like okay this is it
this is this is what I'm gonna do and
then now I'm building successful people
don't make excuses successful people
don't complain if you look at whoever
you want to look up to look at the most
successful people in the world in any
industry look at the top and look at how
much they complain they don't complain
when you complain when you blame
something else when it's the
government's fault or interest rates
fault or the bad economies fault or your
partner who screwed you over or the
customers who don't care as long as you
can blame somebody else right the
education system your parents your
friends your upbringing there's always
somebody else to blame and when you
blame somebody else when you're in that
mindset then you never grow you make it
things easy on yourself it allows you to
coast it
you to play live super safe because it's
not your fault that you're not more
successful of course it's not your fault
that would be difficult that would be
hard it's somebody else's fault so you
can just stay where you are
because people are holding you back from
accomplishing the thing that you want to
accomplish you we're successful people
take responsibility for where they are
in life and they say I don't care about
the government I don't care who is
president I don't care about regulations
that you have or things that you're
holding me back on I will still go out
and get mine and of course there are
other factors of course the country you
come from matters of course education
you have any and the connections you had
growing up of course it matters
but so what you have to play the hand
that you are doubt you have these cards
you have to play those cards and you can
have success one of the things I love
looking at and this is why I do all
these profiles is successful famous
entrepreneurs there is always somebody
who has done way more than you have done
with way fewer resources than you
already have so no matter what terrible
situation that you have in an empathetic
maybe you have count five broken home
maybe you have a really severe
disability that's physically holding you
back from doing some of the things you
want to do you know maybe there's a lot
of pressure on you maybe you have some
disease maybe you have zero money in
your bank account these are real
pressures and I'm empathetic to that but
so what the longer you believe that
those things are gonna hold you where
you are then they will there are people
who have worse conditions less money are
in worse situations and they came out of
it and accomplished amazing things
because they believed that they could
and if somebody looks like you has gone
on accomplish big things then you can
too and it only happens when you accept
responsibility for where you are in life
I had fought for this for what like six
months seven months I really wanted it
and I remember sitting there and and my
agent said to me um I have good news and
bad news good news is you got Ryder as
bad news as you can't do it then why
can't I do it
because it was exactly the same time as
a press tour
but we and she depressed or while she
did our movie so she took how many
flights in and out I took 23 flights
during this shoot during the filming of
this movie
yeah always knew her lies always on time
I I when I read the script it was the
first time and since then it's been the
only time I've ever read something that
I couldn't imagine somebody else playing
and whatever it took
whether I was tired or it didn't matter
for me for this project for instance I
will film that's coming up I'm gonna
film the Ultimate Fighter on Friday I
will jump on the plane as soon as that
flights over fly to sweden and I will
land in Sweden at 6:30 at night the
fight starts at 6:30 I'll go straight to
the arena right we'll do the fights that
night I'll jump back on the plane fly
back to the United States go to Atlanta
right we'll do our fight in Atlanta then
from Atlanta I'll fly straight down to
Brazil for a press conference in Brazil
and then back to Las Vegas the Ultimate
Fighter on Friday how is it possible how
is it on your health how is it with
family you you know you have a wife and
kids how it's a doable you just got to
do it I mean it's just it you have to do
it there's no I mean who's gonna do it
if I don't it has to be done and you
know I do a pretty good job of balancing
and uh you know III make it happen I
make it work people say it can't be done
you watch it's already uh what month is
it March yeah
it's March all right what I want on
April yeah and I've already done what
I've done since since January you
continue like that for the rest of the
year next two years it's gonna be like
that for the next two years for me I
already know and have my mind set and
you know I know that this is what my
life's gonna be like for the next two
years till I get this thing dialed in
all those records is a very important
place
it was the most famous record store in
San Diego and one of the most famous in
the country when blink first started I
drove around about a 20 mile radius from
the store and I broke into every high
school at night and I made blink flyers
and I put them in every single locker at
all these high schools that we were
playing at the club downtown at that
point in time everyone in San Diego
wanted to support their local bands it
was just a really big scene so because I
put those flyers in those lockers we
ended up having on our first show at a
big club all the people came and we had
enough people that watched us that the
guy that owned the club invited us the
following week to play on the big stage
so what we did is not only pulled that
show we rushed and made a really quick
recording and it was our first recording
with a little Buddha statue on it that
people commonly refer to that record as
Buddha we made that to sell here in this
store so we would put five tapes in at a
time there's at the time where tapes are
selling and every week we would call up
and they're all they're gone where they
go my absolute but five more they're
gone so then we gave them 10 their God
they gave him 20 next thing you know we
sold thousands of these tape cassettes
out of his records and then we've got
our start on it was a you know little
suburban kids we had a dream to be in
the punk rock section and I'm here now
looking at all these things I grew up on
and if they're so insanely important to
me try to do absolutely everything like
I it frustrates me to no end or it
sounds more miserable than anything to
kind of be hung up on any step of the
kind of bureaucratic process or like the
you know the
practical process of like getting
somebody to give you the money getting
this actor in it so that she can make it
getting this equipment so that you can
do it it's like just use what you have
you know at your disposal and if you're
new you know the experience even if you
make it on your phone the experience
isn't going to hurt you and what you'll
you know you make a movie on your phone
what you can focus on is story you know
performance and and see if your stuff is
actually playing and then whatever you
don't get into Sundance you don't get
into slam dance fine put it out
somewhere else and make another one
now I've got a special bonus clip for
you from post Malone but before that my
question of the day is what did you need
to make happen right after watching this
video what are you gonna make happen
leave it down in the comments below I
really want to see what you have to say
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clips
graduated high school and then I did
like half a semester in of TCC and I
didn't like it so I just left and went
to LA you know what nothing I moved into
a house with with my friend from from
Texas and you know he was doing well and
you know I kind of like freeloader for a
while you know I'm not proud of that but
you know they gave me a room and
everything cuz I was working and they
really believed in what I was doing so I
had a room but everybody wanted the room
should be the studio I left my room and
then we built the studio in there I
moved into the closet upstairs I had an
air mattress and a mini-fridge and a
little clothesline thing I was folding
my jeans on the floor and shirts on the
rack yeah the most important work ever
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
Apple
that would be collect a little beacon
table Ignatian if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details
[Music]